Con una superficie de 284 mil
kilómetros cuadrados y algo más de 16
millones de habitantes,
Ecuador es el país más densamente
poblado de toda Sudamérica.
Enclavado entre Colombia, Perú y el
Océano Pacífico, es uno de los pocos
países del mundo que carecen de moneda
propia, utilizando desde el año 2000 el
dólar de los Estados Unidos. En los
últimos años, bajo el gobierno de
Rafael Correa, Ecuador se ha convertido
en un modelo a seguir para muchos
políticos, analistas e intelectuales. Sin
embargo, hoy por hoy las cosas no marchan
tan bien. Hoy, en VisualPolitik te hablamos de Ecuador.
La economía ecuatoriana se encuentra atravesando
un difícil momento.
De acuerdo con las últimas previsiones
del FMI,  el banco mundial y otros
organismos internacionales,
el PIB de Ecuador se está desplomando.
Pero, ¿cómo se ha llegado a esta
situación? y ¿cuáles son las auténticas
dimensiones de esta crisis? Para
responder a estas preguntas, tenemos que
remontarnos a inicio del 2007 cuando
asumió el gobierno Rafael Correa y puso
en marcha la conocida como Revolución
Ciudadana, un programa político de corte
chavista-bolivariano que empezó por
todo lo grande:
en 2008, y tras una auditoría realizada
por la llamada Comisión para la
Auditoría Integral del Crédito
Público,
Ecuador anunció el impago de la deuda
considerada como ilegítima.
- " Hay compromisos nacionales urgentes y
nosotros primero pondremos los
compromisos nacionales a los compromisos
internacionales". Personalmente esta moda
de las auditorías de la deuda me tiene
fascinado. ¿Qué culpa tienen los
pensionistas alemanes, por ejemplo, de que
el dinero que prestaron fuera
mal utilizado por quien lo pidió?
Bueno, Rafael Correa aprovechó un
momento de fortaleza económica del
país, un momento en el que la deuda
pública era relativamente pequeña,
unos 10.000 millones de euros, es decir
menos del 1 por ciento de la deuda
pública que tiene hoy España, para
anunciar que suspendía los pagos de
aproximadamente un tercio de la deuda exterior.
- "Dejó dicho que ahorita no puede pagar,
pero que mañana seguro. - ¿seguro?¿seguro?
- Seguro que tampoco". El resultado fue que
ante el miedo a no cobrar los inversores
empezaron a deshacerse de los títulos
afectados vendiéndolos con fuertes
descuentos en el mercado y ¿que ocurrió?
Pues que fue el propio gobierno quien
los compró pagando 35 dólares por cada
título que le obligaba a pagar 100
dólares más intereses.
¡Tal cual! Toda una artimaña, casi un chantaje,
que teniendo como ingrediente principal
el miedo le permitió a Ecuador
ahorrarse pagos por cerca de 7.000
millones de dólares,
eso sí, a costa de retratarse como un
país poco fiable en el que invertir.
- "es algo falso, a una farsa, una filfa, un
artificio, pura fantasía."
Por otra parte el vertiginoso aumento de
los precios del petróleo en la última
década, supuso que el gobierno de Correa
tuviese acceso a una gigantesca cantidad
de recursos económicos y ¿qué hizo con ellos?
Pues disparar el gasto público. Durante
los años del presidente Correa
el gasto público ha crecido a un ritmo
cinco veces más rápido que la propia
economía ecuatoriana.
El resultado es que el tamaño del
estado se ha doblado a lo largo de la
llamada Revolución Ciudadana, y hoy
representa ya casi la mitad de toda la
economía nacional.
Claro, semejante inyección de recursos hizo que la economía creciese y Ecuador
experimentase lo que casi podemos
considerar como una época dorada.
La clase media aumentó, se pusieron en
marcha todo tipo de programas sociales,
la pobreza se redujo en más de un
millón y medio de personas y la
inversión pública en infraestructuras
alcanzó récords históricos.
Además, la educación ha sido una de las
niñas mimadas y hoy Ecuador destina en
ella un 5,3 por ciento del PIB, con lo
que ¡ojo! es el país latinoamericano que
proporcionalmente más dinero gasta en
este concepto.
Tampoco nos podemos olvidar de las
políticas proteccionistas, otra de las
apuestas claras del gobierno ecuatoriano.
- "que sin adecuados mecanismo de
control y gobernanza, esta globalización
puede devastar países".
En definitiva, Rafael Correa y su
Revolución Ciudadana cobraron pronto
mucha popularidad entre la izquierda, tanto
dentro como fuera de Ecuador, e incluso
periodistas españoles tan conocidos como
Jordi Évole, se dirigieron al Presidente Correa
en busca de respuestas y recetas contra
la crisis ¡Casi nada!
Pero ojo amigos, no todo ha sido tan
bonito. A pesar de la narración de
éxito
veamos cuáles han sido las principales
claves de lo que casi podemos denominar
como "crónica de una crisis anunciada":
Entre 2007 y 2015 el crecimiento medio
anual fue del 3,9 por ciento, una tasa
inferior a la de Perú, Paraguay, Bolivia,
Uruguay y Colombia.
Otros países como Argentina o Chile
están casi a la par, así que, podemos
decir que Ecuador solo ha destacado
respecto a la caótica economía de
Brasil y a desastrosa economía de
Venezuela.
Si, además, tenemos en cuenta la mala
evolución actual, observamos que la
economía ecuatoriana ha presentado una
muy pobre evolución durante el período
de Rafael Correa.
A pesar de los beneficios que tuvo el
gobierno de Ecuador con el impago de
la deuda y los más de 80.000 millones
de dólares obtenidos del petroleo
durante este periodo, la deuda pública
se ha disparado.
De hecho, si sumamos todas las
obligaciones, incluyendo los pagos en
petróleo a China, que por cierto se ha
convertido en el mayor acreedor del
país,
la deuda total del Estado se aproxima ya
al 90 por ciento del Producto Interior
Bruto. Cuando Correa llegó al poder la
deuda pública se situaba por debajo del
25%.
Lejos de diversificarse, la economía ecuatoriana sigue siendo muy dependiente del petróleo,
de tal forma que cuando el precio del
crudo se ha desplomado también lo ha
hecho la economía nacional. Al tiempo,
claro, que el déficit público se ha
escapado de todo control.
La situación es tan delicada que para
conseguir liquidez el gobierno
ecuatoriano ha llegado a entregarle a
Goldman Sachs de la mitad de las
reservas de oro del país como garantía
de un préstamo.
Además, la prima de riesgo es tan
elevada que, Ecuador, está emitiendo
bonos a cinco años al 10,5% ¡Más que Grecia!
El resultado es que a pesar de lo que
siempre ha dicho Correa, Ecuador ha
pedido ayuda al mismísimo FMI - "El Fondo Monetario fueron quienes impusieron
pusieron el neoliberalismo en América
latina y en el mundo entero".
Como consecuencia de las trabas existentes, el
excesivo intervencionismo y el miedo de
los inversores,
Ecuador es uno de los países de
América Latina con menor inversión
extranjera directa. Para hacernos una
idea, la inversión extranjera directa en
relación al pib es tres veces
inferior a la de Perú y seis veces
inferior a la que registra Chile.
Si bien la pobreza se ha reducido
sustancialmente, no lo ha hecho a ritmos
mayores que en los gobiernos precedentes y,
además, como es lógico, la pobreza está
ligada a la evolución económica de tal
forma que en 2016
el ratio de pobreza está repuntando
respecto al año anterior.
Por todo ello podemos afirmar que más
que un milagro económico, Ecuador, uno de
los países con menos libertad
económica de la región, ha registrado
durante la etapa de Rafael Correa una gran
burbuja de gasto público. Y como todas
las burbujas, tarde o temprano, explotan. Por
fortuna para todos ecuatorianos, y a
pesar de que ya hay sospechas de
manipulación por parte del gobierno de
los datos económicos,
es poco
probable que la crisis alcance cotas tan
dramáticas como en Venezuela, gracias a
que la economía está dolarizada y para
disgusto del presidente, el Gobierno no
puede recurrir a la impresión de dinero
para financiarse. Por si fuese poco,
Rafael Correa, confeso admirador de
Chávez, ha transformado Ecuador en uno
de los países de América Latina, junto
a Cuba y Venezuela, más restrictivos con
la libertad de expresión.
- "La prensa es bastante mediocre y con
fuertes intereses privados". En fin, que como
podemos ver, este supuesto salvador del pueblo
tan venerado por la izquierda, tampoco
resultó ser como nos contaron. Ahora
te pregunta a ti ¿Cuál es tu opinión?
¿Crees que Ecuador correrá una suerte similar a la de Venezuela? ¿Crees que Correa
a sido beneficioso o perjudicial? Si te gusta
este video dale a like y se te gusta la
política y la economía,
suscríbete a VisualPolitik si aún no
lo has hecho. Un saludo y hasta el
próximo vídeo.